well there was already a ton of hype rod
on this new look rams team now that hype
may just shoot through the the roof here
at sofi stadium let's flip it over to
the chicago bears though two
quarterbacks we saw tonight justin
fields andy dalton where should that
quarterback room go from here
andy dalton is a solid player i mean
he's a solid whether he's a starting
quarterback or if he's a backup he's
solid but it's nothing special about him
and if the bears not just want to get to
the playoffs if they want to go far in
the playoffs they need something special
at the quarterback position and i say
justin fields and you saw when he came
in he's not afraid the stage isn't too
big for him he came in in the first
series and he threw like an eight-yard
out route and then they took him back
out the game so i just i don't agree
with matt nagy i think andy dalton is a
solid quarterback but if you really want
to go to that next level you need to put
justin fields in and just give him this
experience give him that opportunity
chris sims where would you go with this
quarterback room listen i'm uh jack i
think you've heard me say this before
i'm a little bit like rodney or maybe
even coach dungey who talked about it in
football night in america i believe in
justin fields as well you know again
we've seen this bear's offense with the
andy dalton type quarterback 38 complete
38 pass attempts tonight 206 yards
that's just not going to scare defenses
there's no explosive element like
rodney's talking about or specialness
that he can bring to the office you know
the one thing about fields of course is
yeah the brights the lights aren't too
bright for him but he's got big
playability and you saw how the team got
excited hey andy dalton right here yeah
he's going to do all the right things
with the ball we understand that he
understands how to run the offense he's
not going to make big mistakes okay big
whoopee what who cares if justin fields
comes in and makes a mistake here and
there he's also going to make 10 other
plays that andy dalton won't be capable
of making i think that's what we're
missing and then you know we talk about
oh you know the bears offensive line and
we don't want to put anybody well listen
if you're playing defense against the
bears you know where andy dalton's going
to be he's going to be five yards behind
the center you know with with justin
fields there's a million things you got
to worry about you got to worry about
him keeping the ball in a quarterback
design run the read option the rpos and
then of course his ability to scramble
and make plays like that so i am one
that thinks i'd rather see justin fields
here sooner rather than later and i
don't know hey guys did it jump out to
you when justin fields scored that
touchdown just how excited the bears
sideline and team got when he ran in for
that one ends uh that one rushing
touchdown
absolutely and i'll tell you this chris
the players aren't stupid they know when
they want a player and they feel like a
player can make plays they want that guy
in of course they're not going to go
publicly and criticize their head coach
but at the end of the day i'm i'm
concerned about this defense a little
bit is there anything to that patience
as we check out some justin fields play
from tonight is anything to that
patience in terms of just kind of
getting his feet wet here slowly easing
him into the nfl life or should they
just go all in on justin fields i just i
just tell you this i don't know any
other coach general manager that can get
away with what
matt naggy and ryan pace got away with
picking trubisky blowing that and coming
back signing andy dalton giving him the
job and not playing justin fields i just
think it's absolutely crazy and what are
you what are you trying to prove like
justin phil should be the starter i
don't know how tough it is like how hard
is it how much how difficult is it
because you promised a guy job i just
don't like it i don't think it's right
rod flip it over to the bears
defensively what is it going to take for
them to get back to their feared ways on
the defensive side of the ball well
first they got to take care of their
players they got to take care of keem
hicks he's unhappy that he doesn't have
his contract you look at a guy they open
up the checkbook for khalil mack he's
been good he hasn't been great and then
eddie jackson this is a kid that's
making 13 million dollars he was a first
team all pro and he gets beat on one of
the first series plays for a touchdown
he doesn't even tag the guy so
i just i look at the new defense
coordinator sean desai and i just think
that you know eventually he's going to
have to make a move at a certain
position we saw some aaron donald we saw
donald in the backfield a bit khalil
mack your take on his performance
tonight what did you see well khalil is
a hard worker and he's you know
pressures and a lot of times you can't
say okay well he doesn't have 10 double
digit sacks he's constantly putting
pressure and all his teammates come out
and they say hey this dude is a dog he's
tough he's really the leader but at the
end of the day you get paid 20 million
dollars a year to put up numbers he's
working hard he's just got to get to the
quarterback how about cole commet this
tight end because we had an eye on him
you're really thinking you need some
tight end presence he was at the
university
i looked at this dude he is huge he can
run but he's timid he is he's a big dude
like you should be running those little
db's over i just i think the more reps
he gets and they're trying to feed him
they want to feed him and matter of fact
it was a fourth down and four to one we
just talked about with jalen ramsey he
was wide open and andy dalton didn't
trust him to throw him the ball he just
needs to play with a lot more confidence
coach neggie an offensive coach and
every year you're thinking at some point
the offense has to explode right in his
time with the bears the offense has to
go do their thing what's it going to
take for their offense to finally go do
the thing that he was proud here to do
well maybe stop
matt nagy from calling the plays i think
first and foremost
i mean because this offense he's
supposed to be an offensive genius and i
i don't see anything i don't see
anything that makes me say chris i don't
see anything that makes me say wow matt
nag is a great offensive play caller
he's really putting his uh his guys in a
position to have success or he's really
putting a lot of pressure on a defense i
don't know what it is i mean you played
quarterback what do you think about
their offer no i agree there you make a
great point there's no identity with the
bears offense you watch the game
sometimes you go i'm not sure exactly
what they're trying to accomplish here
or make the defense defend to then now
they can play something off off of that
whatever that is we know like mcveigh
they're going to run the ball right and
they're going to run the ball but then
they're going to use the play-action
pass and the speed sweeps and then
screens off of those play-action fakes
and everything like that with the
chicago bears it's hard to tell and then
let alone the drop back pass offense i
think the thing that bothered me more
than anything tonight was listen i know
you know the rams are a talented defense
but you got to do something at some
point to scare the rams defense man they
got to play downhill in the secondary
the back seven all game long every throw
was a five yard throw into a tight
window it's hard to play quarterback
like that it's hard to create big plays
like that and that's where i end up
always going back to the justin fields
conversation just because i think
honestly he gives them the he's the
greatest schematical advantage they have
just like we saw on the touchdown run
you know they don't have a guy like that
he's a special runner so i don't know
where this goes
i know the bears fans of chicago would
be calling for justin fields but yeah i
worry about this bear's offense 100 i'm
with you rodney
let's take a second rod let's hear from
coach nagy after the loss here's what he
had to say
the way you deployed justin fields
tonight
as the game was unfolding what ended up
limiting him to five steps which is what
i think it was yeah um
it was hard to tell if we knew exactly
how many snaps he was going to get but
again once you once you get behind like
we did
and you get back a few scores that's
when you get more into the the
two-minute mode that's probably why
there was a little bit less
but
who knows you know i think that for him
the times that he got in there that he
did well and you know being his first
game and
andy andy did a good job too of helping
extend some of those drives and us going
through that whole deal of how it's
going to go but we'll continue to keep
growing with that stuff and see what we
want to do
with that but uh in the end i thought
and again i go back to that touchdown
run i mean justin did a great job and
then early in the game on the first
throw too you know so um the film going
back and just watching the film in
general regardless of justin or andy
just in general to see where we were i
thought we got the run game going pretty
good which was good but um we got to use
this to grow we got to stay positive
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports